there's a great book called talent is
overrated in the guy the guy the author
of it takes the look at Malcolm
Gladwell's 10,000 hours things and he
goes yeah but it's a great thing of like
you could do 10,000 hours and still suck
asses all right well first of all 10,000
hours means it's it's very misleading
because you have to be practicing the
right way you gotta go that's what this
book you get really good at the wrong
thing yeah you know if you're not
careful so even if you're doing 10,000
hours but it's something not good at
right yeah I mean 30,000 it doesn't
matter this book is I recommend it for
everybody it's a super [ __ ] dry read
but it's really great because what he
does is he does did that exact thing
where he talks about applied practice a
great book yeah you have to you have to
basically practice the thing that you
suck at until it's great to just boost
your that's you know that's way more
talent yes so he'll break up he'll bring
a practice like this so the difference
between say regional swimmers and
Olympic swimmers is actually not time in
the pool and it's not even so much
talent a lot of times what it is is that
when you have an amazing coach that
coach will say to you okay today your
hand is coming out your elbows coming
out this high I need your elbow this
high for a week they'll only practice
that yeah and and and so so Roger
Federer so they only would be the
coaching he's the coaching so Roger
Federer so they think yeah Roger Federer
practices an hour and a half a day now
now the way well but even back in the
day one of the reasons why these guys
because see it's and you know probably
know this but these you can practice six
hours day then you start getting injured
yeah so you've got it you have a little
bit of time yeah so you have a little
bit of time so what they'll do now
especially with tennis which is a lot of
physical you know yeah is is they have
you they very [ __ ] specific very
specific about and then the rest is just
timing keeping your timing where it is
and everything else so that unit is
overrated and he goes through he kind of
goes through like he goes through Jerry
Rice he has a chapter on Jerry Rice
about how Jerry Rice fastest but he
would run those hills because he wanted
to stay fresh in the fourth quarter he
would he would have those hand grasping
rakes and people would be like why are
you doing that he'd always walk around
like that he's like so I can take the
ball away from people that don't have as
strong as hands because people aren't
working there has an obsession that it's
an obsession it's like Brady's out right
yeah training and that's where it is
like Tiger Woods was another so you're
saying just out working they're saying
in the right way smarter
so saying like work on like well after I
read that book I was like alright I
don't sit down and write jokes well so
let me do that until I'm better at
sitting down sighs how are you doing it
I was just you know I would rip
something and then I would write down
like a line and then I go on the swage
then you go onstage and the only time
you're working on it is when you're on
stage which can be highly effective but
I was like well what's my weakness and
that's sitting down and writing out the
jokes cuz I'd hang out with people like
Sam Morril who's like unbelievable honey
so funny but also can sit down and be
like and you're like I I can't I can't
pull from that I can't I would do it now
that guys doesn't feel right but then
you you sit in it and you do it enough
and you start it's like deep practice
they did with musicians they're like
world-class violinist world-class piano
players they will you you have to work
on what you're bad at yeah you're great
oh great you can do all that and then
they make you do these weird things with
your left hand that hurts your hands
yeah that's where they go that's where
you're wrong that's where that you're
not doing so those decisions yeah so you
just you focus on what you're bad at
that's also where people it's funny
saying about stand-up though because I
was sitting around thinking about
metaphors like I'm bad it I'm not as
good at coming up with metaphors yeah so
I've been I've been doing exactly that
just sitting down and kind of going the
next step you ask the next question yeah
I did writing why did you read the book
yeah see it's great yeah and you got it
and you got if you have to fail you have
to fail a lot at it to kind of you know
then you start getting better and then
when you get that little bit of
progression you're like oh [ __ ] I can't
even do this now I can and then it gets
you hyped to be like let me do it more
and that's why I think the danger of
when comics gets super successful is
they start getting insulated by people
that don't be like hey your left hands
off you know what I mean like a musician
like a musician when they blow up
they're like everything you're claiming
isn't perfect yeah like no I mean you
still have weaknesses so it's I think
that's like important when you see when
you see comics and like why are they not
funny anymore and it's like well because
they're keep that he lost an edge though
but it was just people around him that
are like man you're so funny it's
supposed to be like I live with my
Kentucky own who's like he's [ __ ]
funny
funniest I just saw him in New York I'm
with dove and speculum on Chinese and I
go
I'm watching him and double its go back
there I go hold on I gotta watch Becky
own yeah [ __ ] kills dude he is a he
is I mean what I say - really yes my
roommate he's an airtight comedian Oh
airtight kindig you like it like an
Italian kid looks like a cop looks like
a gangster arrest yeah in high school
yeah Russell depends State Oh a wrestler
Penn State
yeah that's a big deal and he is we've
lived together for like eight and a half
years right guy but he's a guy where I'm
like oh yeah dude we live we live in my
Queens I live in a gym dude you guys
date her yeah I mean we're all
common-law husbands thick kid yeah he's
a Penn State yeah and you guys you guys
met in New York yeah I mean we've been
friends just through comedy or whatever
how'd you get from Denver to New York I
just growing up in Denver and you can
mess with there's really no there's like
no creative outlet for if you want to be
a comic comedy works there's comedy
works but there's no like see my face
comes up that's how common-law husband
we are my face comes up when you see our
there's that's vacuum yeah yeah yeah I
interrupted you tell me about what I'm
saying like Becky owns a guy were you I
can constantly check jokes with him
mm-hmm as opposed to if I was by myself
and he just had a lot of yes people
around you and you're like how do you
see one do this joke he's the one you
got to keep people around you that are
kind of like dude I hate to say this
you're down to seller right yeah yeah
and so you're just like you guys is
there any better place is there any
better place to incubate the same better
the stand is up there man where's that
in New York it's in Union Square at the
stand yeah man they they kind of came
the sellers great and I love to sell our
work and so but having the stand and the
seller he's kind of like having two gyms
where you can go and Patrick who books
the stand what I love about him is this
Jesus is open for you to fail he's like
just go try whatever you want there's
two room yeah dude it's great love they
just open the new one and it's [ __ ]
views right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue oh good what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]